well the end of the series let's rank
him so I finished up Series three so
that means it's time to rank all the
stories and because I count two partners
as one story this is in fact going to be
a top ten ranking even though it's not
really top it's just all the episodes
I'm not including any Christmas specials
than this night or any mini so so no
time crash no the Christmas it one
though wouldn't know
[Music]
runaway bride no voyage of the Damned I
don't include the specials when I do
these rankings I only include the
episodes that are considered to be the
series proper so let's Kate let's get to
it we're gonna start down at the bottom
and that will be the Lazarus experiment
I was a little bit surprised when I
actually sat down and ranked these and
it ended up putting this one at the
bottom the thing was that there are
episodes that have problems that make me
a lot angrier there's nothing that
really gets me very worked up about the
Lazarus experiment the thing is even
some of the other episodes that I don't
like very much I can look at them and go
there was an interesting idea there this
is scientist becomes monster this is the
most generic wrote science fiction
horror ish fantasy thing ever if you
don't have a unique spin on it there's
no reason to ever do this story and this
episode does not have a unique spin on
it in any way whatsoever the pacing is
atrocious the effects are laughable the
performance from Mark Gatiss is okay but
it doesn't really sell it all that well
the premise is ridiculous it just
basically has nothing that's good
really and that and that's sometimes
what happens with things at the button
things at the wall
either have something that's really
awful or they just don't have anything
good to lift lift up everything else
that's the case here so it takes the
bottom spot will be up one spots at
number nine we have one that I do think
had some potential but the things that
did work make me angry and that would be
Daleks and Manhattan and evolution of
the Daleks the core idea of the Daleks
trying to evolve and better themselves
because they recognize that they're kind
of stuck and they cannot get and they
cannot improve even though the idea of
improving is somewhat blasphemous to
them that is an idea with potential
bringing back the scheming Daleks as
opposed to the come sweeping in with an
armada and just blow everything up
Daleks we've been getting up to this
point that that was an ideal with
potential and it just doesn't work it
did like on so many levels from tiny
little nitpicky things that apparently
don't bother other people as much as
they do me like the accents holy God
Tallulah's voice nails on a chalkboard
and you know then there's the really
obvious stuff like that first of all the
pink slays Y pigs first of all the show
did pigs it did a pig alien in series
one so why are we doing pigs again and
that effect is okay I guess but then
there's the Dalek human hybrid with its
weird
phallic twitchy face things and that
performance doesn't work worth a dang at
all and this whole idea that like the
doctor gets struck by lightning inserts
his genetic what look this show can get
away with a lot of techno babble and
gobbledygook but this doesn't even seem
like techno babble this is just nonsense
this thing just does not work number
eight another one that's just basically
dull but it's more competent than the
Lazarus experience and didn't take me
off as much as thought I sent Manhattan
an evolution of that Alex that's 42:42
again had a promising idea with the get
with the real time gimmick and just the
ship falling into the Sun that was
plenty it didn't need a monster and the
monster is kind of generic in terms of
execution constants
the monster is cool execution of the
monster is generic it does have that one
great moment of Martha and the escape
pod getting more more distance between
her and the doctor she can't hear him as
he's yelling I'll save you that's a
great moment so unlike Lazarus
experiment it does have a couple of
things that raise it but it's not a lot
it's smaller tiny things whereas the big
core ideas either aren't very good or
aren't utilized properly so yeah this is
down towards the bottom okay now for
number seven and now we start getting
into episodes that I do actually enjoy
and are not ones that I would skip it
was really just those bottom three that
are ones that I'm like I don't really
need to see that again so that brings us
to the Shakespeare code which is goofy
it does the oh we've got witches oh wait
it's aliens thing that you know I'm I've
kind of made uh made like a hobby out of
pointing that out when that stuff
happens so it's got that going on the
carrionites aren't great their music is
quite good though the guy who plays
Shakespeare is great it's got a fun vibe
to it overall Martha and the doctor have
a good rapport although they are the
show does hammer in the Martha is
crushing on him a lot harder a lot
sooner than I thought they did but
there's enough good stuff here largely
in terms of the character dynamics and
interactions and the chemistry between
the performers that helps bring it up
and I still find it enjoyable next up
number six gridlock I've got nitpicks on
this one but I find it a lot of fun a
bit like 42 monster is unnecessary the
Micra don't need to be here it's kind of
a cool nod to the history of the show
but the show this episode does not need
a monster
it does not assist any of the themes or
any of the other things going on with
the episode also the whole idea of the
the mood drugs that was an idea that I
feel like needed to be explored more in
depth here it's really just used as at
the very end as a payoff to explain why
everything went to heck but I feel like
that entire concept could have been
explored in into its own episode I
don't like that he gets thrown away on
this and we also have the cat aliens
back which you know I'll always say that
something that is that clearly an analog
to an animal we already know is lazy
design even if they are supposed to be
an evolution of cats as we know them I
still find that lazy but all that said
Brannigan is a great character actually
pretty much all the supporting
characters are really good have a lot of
personality even the ones that we only
see briefly there's a real sense of time
and of exhaustion with the situation yet
holding on to that hope that kernel of
hope that is not logical and falls apart
in the face of the doctor pointing out a
few basic things like has anybody ever
seen a police car so but just capturing
that all that I really like and the
ending with the face of BOE works for me
too not only because of how pays off
later but just in and of itself I think
that works pretty well so it's got some
hiccups it's got some speed bumps it's
got some wasted elements but overall I
like the vibe and I will always love a
story that takes a simple concept zone
we all know like a traffic jam and finds
a way to blow it up into a sci-fi story
I just like that all right
officially in the upper half number 5
sound of drums and the last of the
Timelords
some people might be surprised as one
came in as high as it did because I
think I did a fair amount of complaining
in that review but ultimately the thing
was the the things that are good that I
kind of shortchanged in my memory of it
are really good and that is primarily
Martha Martha's family some of the
supporting characters but more than
anything the master when speaking with
the doctor when the two of them are
actually playing opposite each other
it's electric it's it's really wonderful
and to see that energy in that history
in that sense of animosity between them
the fact that the doctor wants to let it
go and the master just won't ever you I
can't
put it any higher than this because I do
think it's one of the bigger offending
deus ex machina resolutions overall with
the fact that it rolls back to be the
year worth of time completely and in
addition to that when the master isn't
playing opposite the doctor i find him
just too goofy and too silly but when
this thing's working it's working really
well and the emotional payoff would the
doctor specifically works and Martha the
circumstances in the way that she
chooses to leave I really enjoy it I
think it speaks to her strength as a
character here we go number four Smith
and Jones I think this is a this is one
of the really good companion
introduction stories especially ones
that introduce new command but not
necessarily new doctor because we get
who Martha is quickly we get who she is
we get this she's smart it's
demonstrated it's not just said it's
demonstrated and we get why the doctors
are like oh hey I like you Martha Jones
and I as much as I not a huge fan of the
plasma for as a villain I do really like
the entire place the hospital on the
moon thing and I like the Judoon is that
weird that I'm complaining about that
since they're basically just rhinos
versus the cat people out maybe but at
least it's an incomplete prosthetic head
instead of just you know slapping some
makeup on people so I think I just give
the extra fur to pass but I like the
Judoon I think they're fun and they're
neat and the doctor it's just great to
see the doctor just sort of coming in
and and just doing his thing running
down a corridor and trying to help
everybody he slips right back into it so
easily and Martha keeps pace with him
pretty much right from the beginning
it sets up their dynamic really well it
introduces her really well as a
character and it's just a fun time
number three utopia because I do
consider it separate from sound of drums
and last of the Timelords
not everyone does people do disagree
with me on that but I treated separately
because I liked it so much better than
those first of all dare
jacobi all man so endearing a wonderful
and sweet and kind as jana and then on a
dime on one turn to camera and just the
coldness in his face
the anger behind every word and just to
watch that turn it is awesomely
terrifying and I like the entire I like
the whole thing of trying to get these
people up to whatever you told me you
might be whatever that last speck of
Hope is and especially like if you
already know what's going on the idea
that the master is helping this happened
that's just that just adds to a
wonderful beautiful irony to it I love
having Jack back I love the scene where
Jack is explaining you know to the
doctor what's going on and he's trying
to reset these these rods and whatnot
and the doctor has some do you want to
die and Jack dodges the question I love
that I love the impact of you are not
alone and the doctor's desperation of
know please just don't do this and the
master is going to be the master so yeah
he's gonna do this
it is really phenomenally good stuff so
up to the top two you should know what
they are number two
bling this was a really tough call
between the number two and the number
one spot it like ie if you asked me on
another day I might even flip them
around but for today when I'm recording
this I'm putting blanket number two and
blink is I've said it before and I've
tested it I have said that this is a
test episode to some people in Doctor
Who and people will argue that with me
is like what it's doctor light you don't
even get the character that much like
it's not about selling the character you
get enough of him to get who he is but
it's selling the feel and the vibe and
the potential of the show this is the
kind of thing this show can do it can be
funny it can be scary it can mess with
time and it can give you wonderful
endearing characters that you like right
away this episode does all of that
expertly in one go I will always argue
that I'm not saying watch this and then
go from here I'm saying use it as a test
episode say hey what do you think of
this would you want to see more
something like this I have had success
with this liz is now watching Doctor Who
because I showed her this episode and it
is just so good the angels are
terrifying the concept of them is really
cool the way that the doctor is brought
into the story it doesn't feel like
we're missing him because his presence
hangs around the whole thing because
we've got the Easter egg and the Oh God
the cleverness of how that conversation
goes I love that Sally Sparrow is a
great character Billy Shipton is
wonderfully tragic with the way that he
ends it is sweet it is funny it is scary
it is all this stuff wrapped up into one
thing and it is so great but it doesn't
take the top spot number one spot goes
to human nature in the family of blood
which probably only just edges it out
because since we get just a little bit
more time with these characters both the
ones that we know and the ones were just
meeting that the emotional resonance of
this two-parter hits me a little bit
more than blink could even though blink
has some good emotional moments and
especially as I get older I take a lot
more I place a lot more weight than the
emotional resonance of something
especially with something I'm revisiting
and knowing what feelings stuck with me
so this story of the doctor being human
of martha being next mm practically
being invisible of John Smith being so
like the doctor but yet so distinctly
different from him of Joan Redfern
falling in love and then basically
having to watch another man walk off
with the face of the man she fell in
love with the family of blood the way
they interact and their glee that they
take in what they do and their odd way
of talking it's so creepy and I mean the
scarecrows have a have a great design to
them
the all these characters feel so fleshed
out all these characters that could have
been one-dimensional characters like the
headmaster he feels like he has a
history and he feels like a fully
fleshed out person the other students
and and you know the the young the young
boy with the psychic and the end the
watch and the watch is such a cool idea
to this whole thing is such a it's it's
a concept that shouldn't work we're
gonna make the doctor human I'm sorry
what but it's so good I love this story
so much in it I believe it's the best
story of Series three you may disagree
with me though so why not share your own
ranking whatever your thoughts are
whether it is on the list I gave you or
if you want to share your own ranking
drop something down the comments let's
talk about it bunch of stuff to do
buttons links patreon book Twitter merch
it's all down there click on it or don't
it's ok because at the end of the day
folks you're the council I just run the
meetings and until next time this
council is adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]